(energetic upbeat music)
- [Katie] I'm ready,
let's do this.
- Oh, it's wrong.
- What did you do? (laughs)
- Boo.
(cast booing)
- Hey, welcome back to a new season of
"Lost in Translation".
- [Katie] Woo.
- [Jasmine] Woo.
(cast clapping)
- I can't even read the English.
- March nine large seeds
into the Super Bowl.
- This is just too much to process.
- [Katie] As usual, we take a recipe,
we put it into Google Translate,
and there are gonna be a ton
of surprises this season.
Let's bring out the hint box.
The snow is divided and there is a woman
of seven large beds.
- I'm having a lot of fun, actually.
So make sure to tune in every single week,
so you don't miss out.
- Wow.
- What?
- Hey, this is not going well.
- Wait, do I get any hints?
- Cute shirts everyone.
- [Everyone] Thank you.
- You were,
♪ Already on the right track ♪
- [Jasmine] Are you kidding?
- Season two baby.